[Musica]
sostenibilità d'impresa
sostenibilità e impresa due parole che
ha prima avviso possono sembrare un
ossimoro una contraddizione intrinseca
immagino che tanti di voi pensino questa
cosa ricordo ancora quando nel 2009
inizia a lavorare per questa grande
azienda milanese
occupandomi appunto di sostenibilità una
conversazione che ebbi con un mio ex
compagno di università che mi chiamo
perderli allora manuela di cosa ti
occupi a milano cosa stai facendo e io
ma sai lavoro mi occupo di sostenibilità
una cosa bellissima
e lui sa dove lavora in un'azienda in
una università in un centro di ricerca e
io no i nazi in un'azienda
un'azienda che fa energia fa gestisce
rifiuti lui rimase in silenzio con i
silenzi che capisci che qualcosa non hai
detto qualcosa di sbagliato al tuo
interlocutore e dico ma che cosa ho
detto e lui mi disse
sostenibilità in un'impresa impossibile
sicuramente quello che stai facendo non
è altro che quel famoso greenwashing
quel famoso ecologismo di facciata che
adesso le aziende stanno iniziando a
dichiarare ma che non è assolutamente
sostenibilità
ecco quello che vorrei far stamattina
con voi è provare a raccontarvi come in
realtà davvero le aziende si stanno
impegnando e ci stanno preoccupando
anche aziende che hanno business
particolarmente
impattanti ha avuto una gestazione lunga
e travagliata il primo termine che
identifica queste queste attività questi
processi all'interno delle imprese
proprio corporate social responsibility
ed è un termine che è stato coniato
dall'unione europea nel 2001 che parla
della integrazione su base volontaria da
parte appunto delle imprese delle
preoccupazioni sociali e ambientali
nelle loro operazioni commerciali e nei
rapporti con le parti interessate
come vedete in questo termine si parla
di base volontaria e in effetti è così è
iniziato tutto su base volontaria nel
senso che le prime aziende hanno
iniziato a fare tutta una serie di
attività proprio
volontariamente cercando di in qualche
modo di rendere consapevoli i propri
interlocutori su quelle che stavano
iniziando a fare oggi in realtà non è
più così volontaria la sostenibilità ci
sono tantissime norme che stanno uscendo
soprattutto da parte dell'unione europea
proprio per cercare di indirizzare
fortemente le aziende su questi su
questi temi su queste integrazioni nei
loro processi
tantissimi regolamenti tantissime leggi
e
ma perché l'azienda è diventata così
importante per per le imprese perché la
sostenibilità è diventata così
importante per le imprese lo è diventato
perché a tutti gli effetti sta
diventando una leva di competitività
lo vedete anche voi immagino che avrete
visto tantissime pubblicità in questi
ultimi mesi in quest'ultimo anno parlare
di sostenibilità di cambiamento
climatico di riduzione delle emissioni
di anidride carbonica
le aziende stanno puntando su questi
temi perché hanno visto che i
consumatori sono diventando sempre più
attenti a questi aspetti sempre su più
sensi
scusate soprattutto le nuove generazioni
come voi portate dall effetto di greta
dall'effetto dei ragazzi di friday sport
futures e questo le aziende lo hanno
capito e stanno cercando davvero di
dimostrare che qualcosa si sta facendo
è diventata una leva di competitività
perché incredibilmente anche la finanza
sta iniziando a chiedere alle aziende di
pensare al lungo periodo
per tantissimi anni la finanza al mondo
finanziario
ovviamente ha chiesto alle aziende
gli utili nel breve periodo ha guardato
ai risultati trimestrali
oggi non è più così
diciamo che il vero cambio epocale sia
nel 2012 con una lettera vi sembrerà
incredibile ma una lettera una lettera
che viene inviata alle imprese da un
ricchissime potentissimo banchiere un
signore che si chiama larry fink e che
te è tutt'oggi l'amministratore delegato
di black rock che è praticamente il più
grande fondo di investimento a livello
europeo a livello mondiale scusatemi nel
2012 manda una lettera a tutti gli
amministratori delegati delle aziende su
cui investe e che sono praticamente
tutte le più grandi aziende a livello
mondiale e gli dice signori
dovete ripensare il governo delle vostre
imprese io voglio investire in imprese
che non producono solo valore nel breve
periodo ma producono valori essenziali
nel lungo periodo questo perché è
necessario per la tenuta complessiva del
sistema questo signore che ripeto è uno
dei più grandi banchieri a livello
mondiale per dirvi per darvi dei numeri
blackrock investe oggi circa 10 trilioni
di dollari che più o meno cinque volte
il prodotto interno lordo italiano
quindi capite che è una persona di una
certa importanza nel mondo finanziario
in questo signore dice voglio cambiare
le regole di questo gioco perché è
chiaro che la produzione il profitto nel
brevissimo periodo porta un benessere
immediato ma non lo può portare nel
lungo e questo già in questa prima
lettera un impatto molto forte a livello
mondiale
finché lo capisce è iniziata e decine di
far diventare un appuntamento annuale
nel 2016 è il primo anno in cui finché
nella sua lettera parla proprio dei temi
di sostenibilità d'impresa cioè dei temi
ambientali e sociali e dice se vogliamo
assicurare ritorni sostenibili nel lungo
periodo dobbiamo preoccuparci ad avere
un piano anche se le piante tematiche
ambientali e sociali e nel 2020 capisce
la portata della crisi climatica e
dedica la sua lettera proprio al
cambiamento climatico
in questa lettera fink dice signore il
più grande rischio di impresa oggi non è
il rischio di investimento non è il
rischio di credito è il rischio
climatico è il cambiamento climatico
questo perché se non agite subito se non
fate subito qualcosa se anche voi non vi
impegniate subito su questo aspetto la
vostra azienda tra 10 20 30 50 anni non
esisterà più e voi dovete capire come
gestirlo che impatto può avere sui
vostri business sulle vostre attività
e cosa e io voglio sapere cosa state
facendo e cosa farete per gestirlo e
questo chiaramente come dire cambia
davvero le regole del gioco sul mondo
delle imprese sul mondo della finanza a
livello generale quali sono gli
strumenti che che le aziende stanno
utilizzando per cercare di gestire di
integrare questa sostenibilità nei loro
processi
quando ho iniziato a lavorare appunto
nel 2009 come vi raccontavo prima cui
assunta in questa azienda per redigere
per lavorare al primo bilancio di
sostenibilità del gruppo che cos'è un
bilancio di sostenibilità io non so se
molti di voi ne hanno mai visto uno o li
conoscono solo dei documenti in cui le
imprese
raccontano i loro impegni sugli aspetti
ambientali e sociali per sociali intendi
tutto quello che fanno per i loro
dipendenti i loro clienti i loro
fornitori le comunità in cui operano ma
soprattutto sono dei documenti in cui
potete trovare tutta una serie di dati
quantitativi riferiti a consumo di
risorse emissioni prodotte rifiuti
prodotti e rifiuti recuperati piuttosto
che dipendenti assunti numero di
infortuni ore di formazione fatte sui
dipendenti
soddisfazione dei clienti fornitori
locali attivato tutta una serie di
informazioni che fino a quel momento non
si trovavano da in altri documenti non
erano strutturate in qualche documento
quindi nel 2009 la mia azienda decise
abbastanza pionieristica per quell epoca
di cercare di iniziare a raccontare
quello che stava facendo ea prendersi
anche degli impegni perché è chiaro che
tutti questi dati venivano già misurato
in azienda ma non erano mai stati
comunicati comunicarli all'esterno vuol
dire chiaramente prendersi anche degli
impegni
praticamente in questi documenti voi
trovate delle
delle pagine in cui ci sono delle
informazioni su quello che l'azienda si
sta impegnando a fare su quei dati che
ha misurato e quindi troverete dei
documenti in cui si dice che l'azienda
si impegna per i prossimi cinque anni a
ridurre il proprio consumo di acqua di
un tot per cento piuttosto che a ridurre
il numero di infortuni dei propri
dipendenti a crescere le erogazioni che
dalle comunità locali degli impegni
concreti il vero cambio di passo sia
quando questi piani vengono integrati
nei piani industriali oggi le aziende
più
evolute diciamo su questi aspetti su
questi temi hanno
integrato proprio questi obiettivi di
sostenibilità all'interno dei loro piani
industriali e soprattutto i temi legati
al cambiamento climatico sono diventati
prioritari perché come vedevamo prima il
mondo della finanza lo richiede e quindi
troverete tantissime aziende che oggi
pubblicano appunto dei piani industriali
in cui le prime informazioni che danno
solo i loro impegni legati alla
riduzione delle emissioni di anidride
carbonica lo fanno attraverso delle
verifiche che fanno anche degli elite e
terzi e di fianco a questo obiettivo
inseriscono poi loro obiettivi di
crescita sui ricavi e sul margine
operativo lordo i classici obiettivi che
si trovano poi in un piano industriale
un altro aspetto che sicuramente le
aziende stanno facendo è quello di
rivedere proprio il loro governo come
chiedeva fink nella prima lettera per
quest'anno creando tutta una serie di
strutture dedicate all'interno delle
aziende come quella in cui lavoro io in
cui le persone si occupano proprio di
questo di cercare di far sì che la
sostenibilità sia integrata in tutti i
processi non solo nella comunicazione e
nell'informazione ma proprio nella
gestione dei dipendenti piuttosto che
appunto dei clienti piuttosto che delle
comunità in cui l'azienda opera e questo
è forse l'aspetto più interessante
ci sono tante aziende che oggi ascoltano
le comunità in cui operano i cittadini
le istituzioni le associazioni di
categoria locali per cercare di capire
quello che sono le esigenze di queste
persone e integrarle nei loro processi
decisionali per creare quello che viene
chiamato oggi valore condiviso l'azienda
ha capito che per avere successo
economico deve creare anche benessere
sociale questo per tantissimi motivi
sicuramente il tema anche della
legittimità ad operare che ha su questo
quei territori ma piuttosto che
l'attrattività che può dare nuovi
talenti e chiaro che nel momento in cui
il posizionamento di questa azienda
diventa legato a tematiche di
sostenibilità tutto il sistema attorno
diventa diciamo in qualche modo
sostenibile e favorevole a questa
azienda e questo è uno degli impegni più
grandi che le aziende stanno stanno
portando avanti anche a livello per
dirvi dell udi unione europea si sta
proprio ragionando sul fatto di
modificare questo questo diciamo quello
che è stato per decenni il
porto la missione della delle aziende
creare valore per gli azionisti sul
creare valore per gli stakeholder cioè
per tutte le parti interessate
e chiaro le aziende stanno facendo tanto
è difficile comunicare questi aspetti è
difficilissimo
a volte sono un po ostici questi bilanci
di sostenibilità soprattutto sono dei
documenti molto corposi però come dire
in qualche modo di aziende ci stanno
provando io infatti mi infervoro sempre
un po quanto sento dire ma sì quella
pubblicità ok ma è greenwashing come
dicevo al mio amico ancora nel 2009
e vero potrebbe anche essere green
washing quello che voglio dirvi oggi e
che in realtà la possibilità di
verificare se effettivamente quella
azienda quel marchio che vi interessa di
cui volete acquistare qualcosa sia
effettivamente sostenibile c'è
praticamente in tutti i siti aziendali
tutti i siti web delle principali
aziende c'è una sezione dedicata alla
sostenibilità in cui potete trovare in
queste informazioni questi documenti
quindi quello che vi dico è che la
possibilità di informarsi e di capire se
è davvero sicuramente le aziende devono
fare ancora tanto in termini di
comunicazione in termini di
consapevolezza di questi aspetti ma
l'impegno c'è ed è un impegno che
vogliamo raggiungere tutti quanti per
creare quello che è il nostro futuro il
futuro vostro futuro nostro e il futuro
delle aziende
grazie
[Applauso]